[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros el documental en france 24
cierre blanco como siempre un gusto
saludarlos hace dos años un grupo de
jóvenes judíos y árabes franceses
decidieron crear un frente unido contra
el antisemitismo y el racismo a través
de una iniciativa llamada eso ese
racismo también en sus diferentes
orígenes y religiones emprendieron una
campaña de concientización a nivel
nacional en un intento por abrir el
diálogo sin filtros en las comunidades
donde estos temas se han convertido en
un completo tabú la reportera hanna
assulín siguió a estos jóvenes en su
misión de hacer que la gente se decida y
hable veamos este reportaje
[Música]
todos estos jóvenes nacieron durante los
años 90
su generación fue la que creció en ese
mundo
[Música]
año tras año han visto instalarse lo de
la tribu alimentado por quienes jugaron
con su sufrimiento y su frustración con
tratar de enfrentar los unos contra
autos
[Música]
asistieron impotentes al estallido de su
horizonte común cada uno en su soledad
con sus miedos y sus aislamientos
[Música]
sin embargo esta juventud quiere seguir
soñando seguir viviendo es generosa
combativa y hoy en día desea que se
escuche su voz
en noviembre de 2018 un grupo de jóvenes
franceses y árabes decidió unirse para
luchar en conjunto contra el racismo y
el antisemitismo
[Música]
porque judíos y árabes porque estuvieron
en el corazón de los conflictos que
sacudieron a francia porque la
actualidad siempre los enfrentan y
porque si ellos no logran creen que
todos pueden lograrlo
[Música]
por iniciativa de la asociación eso es
racismo decidieron recorrer las
carreteras de francia para ir a
encontrarse con otros jóvenes para
reabrir el diálogo en todas partes si te
digo judíos y árabes que me contestaría
en francia eso que te evoca jóvenes que
vienen a expresar su deseo de vivir
juntos
y que afirman que francia también son
ellos juntos
[Música]
mis dos padres son judíos mi madre nació
en marruecos y mi padre nació en argelia
hay personas que quieren utilizar
nuestros miedos utilizar nuestros
temores para estigmatizar al otro como
mi nombre es marihuana
crecí en parís en un barrio que se llama
perdido estoy muy contenta de estar
delante de ustedes hoy soy judía de
origen sefardí mis abuelos nacieron en
argelia y mis padres nacieron en francia
yo soy francés de origen marroquí y
argelino o marroquí del lado de mi padre
y argelino del lado de mi madre recién
el 93 al lado de parís
[Música]
es la primera vez que hay tantos judíos
a nuestro alrededor
honestamente aquí en el barrio o están
escondidos y no lo creo pues que no hay
ninguno ni siquiera sabemos si hay un
barrio judío en antes y un barrio judío
en antes pero que nunca en mi vida me he
encontrado con judíos andantes nunca
hemos escuchado muy poco un discurso
positivo sobre los judíos es decir aquí
en antes nosotros no conocemos a los
palillos en todo caso en este barrio y
en el caso de la mayoría de los jóvenes
me corrigen si me equivoco no sabemos
qué es un judío para nosotros un judío
es lo que vemos en la televisión es
decir tradicionalista es decir que mata
a los palestinos eso significa que es el
gran lobo malvado
si pasa un rabino por aquí lo apedrean
lo insultan porque aquí las personas no
están acostumbradas no nos conocemos y
cuando algo no se conoce la única
interpretación que puede haber de esa
persona es lo que se ve a través de los
medios oa través de los discursos
yo soy racista los odio los detesto 100%
pero a quien detesta a los israelíes yo
los detesto pero hay muchos israelitas
que no son para nada así hay muchos más
cuando vas a solá a la plaza sola
con muchos judíos y les ves la cara los
miras de frente si creen tipos
superiores aquí habla de los israelitas
como si fueran una sola y misma voz es
peligroso lo que estás haciendo es como
si dijeras que un turco habla igual hay
que tener cuidado es como aquí estamos
en una sala no hay una sola persona que
piense igual a otra es peligroso hacer
eso ten cuidado mi padre tiene la
nacionalidad israelí no se puede vivir
allá a los 17 años si tiene la
nacionalidad
entonces ya ves cuando dices así los
israelíes etc
para mí es violento no lo que él piensa
yo lo pensé en algún momento antes
durante mi juventud en realidad aquí
alrededor hay mucha gente así no se
quiera los judíos así es porque uno no
los conoce cuando usted está en parís
vio en una gran en fin es muy grande hay
varios distritos entonces usted se
encuentra con muchas más personas que
nosotros mientras que nuestro caso habrá
un barrio pequeño y si no vamos no los
veremos así tratamos de cultivar no sé
si tratamos de conocerlos tal vez así
podremos empezar a saber quiénes son
realmente cuáles son sus canicas que es
una hoja si no me parece normal que no
te guste alguien que tengas ideas sobre
una persona sólo porque es judío porque
es árabe yo viví momentos en los que
sentía que era maltratado por ser árabe
y si no quisiera que siga siendo así es
por eso que entré al proyecto de ex
aspas consejo sexual g del pollo pero en
realidad porque luchan contra el
antisemitismo o contra los anti judíos
no sé que los racistas contra los judíos
hay muchos racistas contra los
afrodescendientes árabes judíos y
entonces
en realidad nadie voy a hablar sobre los
judíos ni nosotros conocemos un judío
hemos visto uno es interesante hablar
sobre eso porque justamente no se sabe
quiénes son los que sienten pero sobre
los musulmanes afrodescendientes árabes
y todo lo demás todo el mundo ha
escuchado hablar y vinieron hoy nos
hablaron de lo que sienten y de lo que
son pero si no hubieran venido hoy
nosotros todavía ignoramos este tema
usted es el objetivo de este proyecto es
mostrar que los judíos y los árabes no
están hechos para odiarse y pueden vivir
juntos en francia en paz y pueden luchar
juntos contra el racismo y contra el
antisemitismo y que pueden tener las
mismas luchas yo creo que están haciendo
demasiado por nada para qué sirve todo
lo que hacemos para cambiar las cosas
sube si entonces no nos sirve de nada
pues entonces ellos son andrés
personaron cuando está cerrado así es
que se atraviesa un muro nosotros por
ejemplo yo soy musulmana hay personas a
las que no les gustan los musulmanes
pero mire a mí alguien me dice a ti no
te quiero porque eres musulmán a usted
desde que yo voy a dejarles que me digan
que no me quieren porque soy musulmana
al menos lo habrá intentado
mi objetivo es que no se cierren o
incluso
no logré al menos lo habrá intentado
exactamente tú haces tu trabajo tratas
de cultivarlo entonces creo que deberías
pensar antes de hablar porque dices
cosas un poco fuertes
hoy los jóvenes del tour van a un centro
social situado en un barrio popular
cerca de san juan en un suburbio
parisino después de nantes esta vez van
a reunirse con un público mucho más
joven
las líneas pueden presentarse no tengan
miedo no sientan vergüenza
no
ha habido racismo así que al cabo de un
momento se dieron cuenta de una
violencia y se rebelaron contra eso creo
que lo más impresionante fue hembra hawk
en serre chevalier aquí en la estación
de skype todos los días pasaba la gente
y no sacaban el dedo o trataban de
atropellarlos un tipo aceleró se detuvo
a esta distancia en bruja min y
claramente se notaban que no estaban
acostumbrados a ver árabes y
afrodescendientes esa salida fue
realmente impresionante porque fue el
día que los jóvenes empezaron a decirnos
pero eso de verdad existe ahora nos
reímos pero a veces uno puede decirle a
alguien maldito a árabe o los judíos son
así es verdad que hay clichés pero no se
cree que sean violento uno piensa que es
malvado no que es racista pero más allá
de eso incluso para nosotros como
adultos es difícil de manejar es
mirarlos y pensar si supieran lo que les
espera realmente se debe hacer algo y
por eso acudimos a ustedes en mi familia
ya he escuchado que mi madre mi padre no
aceptan mucho a los judíos
en fin apenas se habla sobre los judíos
para ellos es algo malo y yo no entendía
porque hoy en día todavía no entiendo
por qué incluso dijo una vez lo que hizo
hitler estuvo bien que lo que hizo
hitler estuvo bien así cuando dijo eso
tú estabas ahí le contesté este algo yo
era pequeño no sabía mucho pero de todas
maneras te acuerdas sí
trato de entender de dónde vienen los
clichés de dónde vienen las ideas porque
no es insignificante lo que dijiste
sobre tu tío al que le parece bien lo
que hizo hitler
entonces le parece bien que se haya
matado a seis millones de judíos eso
entra en una lógica yo creo que es bueno
la próxima vez que diga eso tal vez
pensarás en nosotros
sí bueno tal vez nunca más lo vuelva a
decir
[Música]
así
la última vez que este nuevo seno centro
yo hablé con un pequeño realmente eso me
marcó nos explicó que en su familia
escuchaba expresiones como tener un
corazón yo iba cuando peleaba con su
hermana su madre le decía que en su casa
le habían dicho lo que le conté la otra
vez que uno de sus tíos le había dicho
que de manera general le había hecho un
buen trabajo cosas bueno precisamente
eso nunca al líder retó a que encuentres
un ejemplo de una familia judía que se
alegre por un pogromo por una
deportación de una exterminación o por
un asesinato porque alegrarse por eso
hay judíos que recientemente se han
comportado de manera muy cuestionable
frente a los migrantes se publicaron
unos artículos en la especie de
periodicuchos de calle pero elsa eso qué
tiene que ver que tiene que pues es la
verdad sí pero no tienen nada que ver
entonces no se puede hablar de lo que
tiene que ver espera nomás con ese
lenguaje con ese discurso pero es verdad
es una realidad no hay personas que son
cerradas de espíritu entre alumnos y yo
no estoy para nada de acuerdo contigo
elsa pero es el problema es que quieres
hacer la comparación es molesto de todas
maneras podemos hablar de cosas sin
hablar de simetría que él se alegre por
hitler no significa que los judíos no
por un claro que no no estoy diciendo
eso entonces no has entendido nada de lo
que te he dicho desde hace un rato
justamente estoy tratando de decirte que
no hay simetría que no hay un punto de
comparación pero no estás obligada a
competir así de acuerdo es ah
vamos a hacer eso entonces vamos a hacer
eso bueno quiere es un pedazo de salmón
no gracias nos hiciste una buena comida
grabó mucha bilis cuando ocurrió la
historia de ilan halimi siempre me
acordé de esa mañana antes de ir a la
marcha era un domingo en la mañana era
sofocante y realmente se sentía algo en
el plano emocional era muy fuerte en
términos casi de terror había algo
aterrador tierra no pero de verdad era
atroz qué pensaste cuando estabas en la
marcha y que ustedes no eran muchos que
sólo había un pero no es que fuéramos
pocos sino que había judíos pero antes
todo el mundo se moviliza de eso no
despertó las conciencias de todos antes
todo el mundo se habría aliado porque
nosotros que fuimos educados allí quiero
decir en fin era inexistente todo eso
inexistente inexistente y estuvimos
durante los buenos años en los que hubo
una verdadera fraternidad cuando nos
manifestábamos cuando éramos unos
jóvenes estudiantes cuando ocurrió lo de
mali kusek y todo el mundo salió a las
calles no pasaban cosas del estilo tal
población sale y tal otra no carpentras
te acuerdas pero claro todo el mundo
estaba unido para protestar era
carpentras explica marian cementerio que
había sido profanado por la extrema
derecha del mundo había salido todo el
mundo había manifestado más que la
desaprueba
el disgusto pero en este caso había una
división había terminado
y cuando uno se fija en la historia de
la comunidad sobre la que se habla pues
cobra sentido porque las personas se
encuentran en una comunidad como la
exclusión sí porque finalmente es lo que
queda cuando ya no hay más comunión
nacional eso es ahora yo siempre he
visto este tipo de disputas de peleas de
riñas entre judíos árabes en los barrios
sí pero seguía siendo manejable
exactamente y además eran personas que
vivían juntas y que a fin de cuentas se
amaban por eso le he dedicado mucho
tiempo porque yo mismo estabas un poco
en negación en el 2006 no era negación
no era una cuestión de negación yo he
hecho música árabe soy músico y he hecho
música oriental
estuve en argelia tenía 17 años
frecuentaba musulmanes todo el día y me
sentía muy bien al mismo tiempo hacía
música para festividades en francia- en
la comunidad judía pero también a veces
en la comunidad musulmana de crisis y a
veces con músicos judíos y con músicos
musulmanes que eran todos como hermanos
a
no no
sí
ah
si existe un barrio que encarna la
coexistencia entre judíos y árabes en
francia es belbel
nosotros no hablamos sobre el aspecto
religioso sino que hablamos de judíos y
árabes
hablamos de pueblos desde hace muchos
años este barrio popular de parís
encarna a la vez las dificultades y las
tensiones que existen entre estas
comunidades pero también una fraternidad
siempre posible y con vida nos fuimos a
hacer un tour de francia es bueno es
satisfactorio hay judíos árabes pues
cayeron en la trampa
vamos
[Música]
cuenta
la un
[Música]
estamos debatiendo sobre la relación
entre los judíos y los árabes es un
barrio judío árabe francés los tres
viven en el mismo barrio estoy aquí hace
20 bueno en 20 años ha cambiado un poco
ha cambiado porque ha cambiado ha
cambiado hay menos judíos ahora y además
las historias
[Música]
- menos judíos porque hay menos judíos o
fueron tal ves ya no están tan
tranquilos como antes en este barrio
[Música]
l
esta noche tan reúne a todos los jóvenes
del proyecto en su casa para una escena
es la ocasión para que el grupo se
encuentre por fuera del tubo para que se
conozcan mejor y puedan hablar
imagínese
[Música]
soy la primera voy a empezar
cronológicamente fue con los atentados
del 13 de noviembre de 2015 estaba muy
impresionada por lo que había pasado
porque había sido justo al lado en
realidad todo lo que siguió después me
sacudió todavía más hasta el punto de
llorar en mi casa en realidad era por
todos los temas relacionados con el
diseño en francia- los musulmanes
realmente tienen su lugar el islam
realmente tiene su lugar el velo
realmente tiene su lugar y la verdad me
sentía muy mal los medios realmente
alinearon el islam queremos algo exógeno
a francia que veníamos de marte que no
teníamos nada que hacer aquí que éramos
terroristas y me hacía mucho daño ver
todos esos debates las 24 horas durante
seis meses deje de ver esos programas
eso me hacía llorar me sentía
profundamente mal más sobre todo por eso
estoy en este proyecto para tratar de
renovar la palabra
que nos apropiemos y que no sigamos
dejando que otras personas se apropien
del debate
[Música]
y marwan se dirigen a perfil y en los
suburbios parisinos es una de las
ciudades más cosmopolitas de francia
a todos los jóvenes presentes ese día
ahí son habitantes del barrio los únicos
judíos que realmente conozco son mis
médicos en fin mi médico personal al que
voy desde que nací y que me hizo la
circuncisión
y que te hizo a mí que me hizo la
circuncisión está bien no está mal es un
detalle importante yo siempre he
frecuentado y siempre he visto judíos
pero había sobre todo una historia común
en una misma frase se decía todo lo
contrario siempre estaba por ejemplo el
tema de los judíos son ricos en esa
época yo podía decir eso pero al mismo
tiempo mi vecino tenía la misma vivienda
social que yo y en realidad también
tenía dificultades igual que yo en mi
círculo no verbal entre mis amigos e
incluso entre mi familia algunos todavía
tienen esos prejuicios y francamente no
puedo culparlos no hay relación entre
nosotros realmente no la hay hay una
barrera entonces no se puede amar a
alguien al que no se conoce hay una idea
que circula pero no creo que sea solo de
los árabes hacia los judíos o algo así
sino que hay personas que dicen que los
judíos controlan la sociedad
y que controla los medios que controlan
eeuu y entonces al mundo etc
lo inmundo de que se te haga yo creo que
son fightnews en realidad no es el judío
control del mundo es el judío que es
rico lo logra y entonces se convierte a
los judíos en unos chivos expiatorios
porque se dice además controlan los
medios y por eso simplemente muestra un
malestar en la sociedad porque le echa
toda la culpa a los judíos cuando uno
agrede un judío no solo lo agrede porque
es judío sino porque se tiene la
impresión de que es por culpa suya que
uno fracasa
a lo largo de las discusiones los
jóvenes se impresionaron cada vez más
por el desconocimiento de unos y otros
entonces se decidieron realizar un
encuentro entre dos grupos de
estudiantes
uno de un liceo judío y los otros de un
liceo público
[Música]
nos alegra mucho recibirlos y sobre todo
nos alegra participar en este proyecto
que consiste justamente en deshacer los
clichés es importante también que
nuestros alumnos se encuentren con
ustedes que nuestros alumnos sepan que
no están solos en francia lo que más
duele no es tanto ser insultados es que
lo que más duele es sentirse solo es
sentirse abandonado todos los judíos
alrededor de esta mesa están en una
escuela judía la mayoría desde que son
muy pequeños y la mayoría incluso
después de salir permanece entre judíos
yo no conocía para nada el medio no
judío eso es algo muy muy grave y cuando
uno se queda en su medio como todos los
medios con palabras fuera de contexto
racistas el set estas palabras se
desarrollan sin ninguna oposición porque
todos estamos juntos entonces podemos
seguir diciendo eso sin problemas y eso
genera grandes tensiones mi madre estaba
en un colegio laico y tenía amigos
judíos y amigos no dice dios y todo
siempre iba bien y poco a poco los
tiempos cambian y desafortunada
pasaron muchas cosas pero ellos también
entraron más en la religión entonces
quisieron que yo también tuviera un
círculo más religioso
con clases de formación judía de cuántos
años muchos y que tenemos miedo tengo
miedo de ser rechazada a causa de mi
religión porque por ejemplo se digo soy
de confesión a dos hermanas
entonces a no mira lo que han hecho por
ejemplo un atentado mira ustedes
hicieron eso ustedes hicieron ángel
sabiendo que yo no tengo nada que vieron
esa historia ha tenido miedo de decir
eres mosúl
varias veces por culpa de ellos más
incluso me da miedo la persona racista
que va pensión que no me van a tratar
como de manás por ejemplo cuando estoy
entre personas de origen francés
me siento todo el tiempo al margen pero
eso es así pues pensaba a mí no me gustó
lo que él dijo respecto a eso dijo que
no es un nombre francés
que ella tenía que llamarse el core y no
tener un nombre de calendario
web
esta fuerte esta historia que piensan
los demás son puras buenas a ti te hace
pensar mucho cuando escuchas a alguien
decir app saturno es un nombre francés o
no debería llamarse así es humillante es
humillante yo en su lugar me habría
sentido humillada pero de todas maneras
fue ella la que lo sintió pues sí
por un lado decir apsa tú no es un
nombre francés de golpe significa este
no es tu país es lo que dice álex en
absa tú sí y el chaleco amarillo que le
dice alain finkielkraut regresa a tu
país eso también quiere decir este
tampoco es tu país en realidad todo el
mundo tiene oído es malvado da una
sensación un poco como de exilio ve de
auxilio
[Música]
cuando ocurrieron los atentados yo tenía
amigos que no son ni judíos ni árabes y
ni por ejemplo te juro que a veces me
acuerdo de momentos en los que me pasaba
una hora explicándole que así no era el
islam y cuando me acordé de eso pensé
porque traté de convencerlo hasta traté
de convencerlo tenía la impresión de que
tendría que justificarme yo en tanto
ahora vemos un mayor que en realidad era
muy molesto que es un ave que hizo los
atentados porque lo hizo en nombre del
islam y yo soy un árabe y soy un
musulmán entonces uno de mis semejantes
fue el que hizo eso yo debía justificar
que no no es eso así no es el islam son
locos no representan nada y en realidad
me pregunto si estuvo bien justificarme
o si no estuvo bien justificarme por
ejemplo si no le hubiera explicado eso
allí ni él habría entendido que eso en
realidad es falso y pensé si me
justifiqué eso quiere decir que yo tengo
algo que reprocharme a mí mismo si en
realidad es desestabilizante uno no sabe
dónde meterse ni siquiera se sabe qué
pensaron botnets empacó apostilló
o entonces te dicen eres musulmán pero
no eres practicante porque si dices que
eres practicante no sé dónde comienza la
práctica y dónde termina
y el que dio las cuchilladas en londres
s
sí sí sí cuando ocurrió ese atentado es
una pequeña plegaria en mi cabeza rece
para que no fuera un árabe para que no
fuera un musulmán a causa de ellos se
ponen en contra de nosotros entiendes y
honestamente sentimos pánico en vez de
pensar sólo en las víctimas también
pensamos en lo que hizo el atentado no
queremos que sea un árabe
eso es muy grave es exactamente eso la
doble pena en realidad es exacto cosas
porque las pobres víctimas no pidieron
nada son familias que quedan
completamente devastadas se rompen
uruguay y después en toda una comunidad
que resulta que por eso
y también está el tema de la identidad
en este caso por ejemplo dan y marouane
por ejemplo esa y yo yo me presenté como
árabe
marouane como árabe como judío y esa
como judía pero no somos sólo eso se
pueden hacer muchas cosas por ejemplo
marouane puede identificarse por su
cocina es un buen cocinero o yo por
ejemplo si puedo presentarme como los
talentos futbolísticos felicito pero lo
que nos viene es que todos somos
franceses y lo que nos une también es
nuestro compromiso el compromiso
ciudadano creo que ahora me convertí en
un militante anti racista por ejemplo
hace un rato antes de tomar la palabra
quería decir algunas cosas tomé la
palabra outlet terminé y pensé 'ya pero
[__] sean finalmente dije lo que en
realidad quería decir
pero eso siempre pasa su esposa pienso
que con el tiempo vamos a aprender a
decir lo que pensamos como lo hacen
marwan
de todas maneras ya decir eso pero
también francamente te las arreglas pero
tú también
y yo soy más yo tengo la impresión de
que yo solo tengo el carisma más allá de
eso
a lo largo de los encuentros ocurren
cambios entre los jóvenes
dudan sus certezas son sacudidas
aprenden a escucharse los unos a los
otros y también a pensar en contra de
ellos mismos frente al contacto con el
otro crecen
[Música]
esta vez elsa dan y marwan tienen una
cita en un centro social en gas legón en
esta ciudad del suburbio parisino está
al lado de sax el que algunos llaman la
pequeña jerusalén a causa de la cantidad
de judíos que viven ahí
[Música]
para todos
en 2014 en el marco del conflicto
israelí-palestino la ciudad se encendió
sus habitantes quedaron muy marcados por
este episodio particularmente violento
realmente había un ambiente de guerra
con helicópteros además no se podían
tomar los trenes había policías estaban
armados ni te digo como caminaban aquí
por las calles al primero que pasaba le
caía un chorro de lacrimógeno realmente
era la guerra verdaderamente la guerra
había personas que gritaban muerte a los
judíos en la calle y en ese momento hubo
momentos un poco incómodos con los
vecinos algunos bajaban la cabeza en el
ascensor no nos hablaban decían buenos
días pero uno sentía que ellos estaban
igual de cómodos que siempre hubo una
amiga en particular a la que en realidad
yo conocía desde que estaba muy pequeña
en ese momento en su facebook vi una
foto en la que ella decía hitler no
terminó su trabajo y esa niña había
comido en mi casa yo había comido en su
casa de verdad crecimos juntas estuvimos
en preescolar juntas jugábamos juntas en
general todos tenemos una etiqueta no es
nuestro nombre sino la judía es verdad
ni siquiera nos llaman por nuestro
nombre hay personas que ni siquiera
querían hablar conmigo porque soy judía
en realidad los afrodescendientes han
sufrido más que los judíos no nomás ha
sufrido igual a los judíos se trata de
la cantidad unos menos y otros más no se
trata simplemente de dos tipos de
sufrimiento distintos pero en todos los
casos estas dos poblaciones han sufrido
yo no entiendo la competencia victimaria
de decir quién ha sufrido más que el
otro el deber de memoria se hace para
todo el mundo a menudo se comparan los
dos sufrimientos porque en realidad los
afrodescendientes han sufrido mucho
durante varios siglos y no sé bien pero
para ellos sigue siendo complicado
buscar trabajo hay muchas
discriminaciones hay racismo y no nos
vamos a mentir los afrodescendientes
están mucho menos protegidos que los
judíos por ejemplo es real aunque los
judíos también han sufrido y siguen
sirviendo por estar más protegidos por
ejemplo antes hablábamos de la sinagoga
y al frente hay soldados mientras que el
caso de los afrodescendientes no lo sé
son vulnerables yo voy a hablar como
francesa judía cine desde hace unos años
fue de repente de la noche a la mañana
porque eso realmente pasó de la noche a
la mañana hace diez años no existía eso
pusieron soldados con armas y vigilancia
policial delante
escuelas judías y delante de las
sinagogas o incluso a veces delante de
los almacenes kosher porque hace unos
años alguien entró con un arma a una
escuela judía en toulouse y le disparó a
quemarropa en la cabeza a una niña
pequeña porque era judía pero eso es una
locura en francia no se había matado a
niños judíos por ser judíos desde la
shoá y desde la deportación voy a decir
algo tengo un hermano pequeño que tiene
11 años durante unos años estuvo en la
escuela judía durante toda esa época no
por esas razones pero estaba en una
escuela judía yo llevaba a mi hermano a
la escuela y eran normales era como tú
decías tranquilo buen ambiente uno se
quedaba al frente se podía estacionar y
de la noche a la mañana un lunes en la
mañana llegamos había soldados con
kalachnikov que estaban así de pie y nos
revisaban la maleta y nos decían que nos
largamos rápido una vez que hubiéramos
dejado al niño y pues era raro pero yo
no pensé hoy tengo suerte estoy
protegida pensé pero que es este mundo
de locos en el que vivimos
potter para muchas personas de la
comunidad judía la policía en realidad
es la que nos protege de una potencial
violencia contra nosotros
y por otro lado siendo un poco directo
para los afrodescendientes y los árabes
en los barrios los policías en realidad
son los que vienen a agredirlos a mí eso
me ponía muy mal porque no lograba
entender cómo era posible salir de eso
es muy simple por ejemplo en mi caso he
tenido muchos controles molestos de la
policía por ejemplo fui a parís a la
casa de mi primo vive en el distrito 20
y la policía me detiene me llevan a un
lado me requisan me desvisten delante de
todo el mundo pasan los transeúntes los
que bajan los que suben me tienen así
durante 10-15 minutos y cuando pregunto
por qué me están controlando a tenemos
un papel de la prefectura muestra su
bolsillo y se va rápido evita el templo
o por ejemplo una noche estaba abajo de
mi casa con mi hermano y dos amigos
nuestros no requisan llegan y nos
regimos me echan el perro encima el
perro ladra debía ser medianoche es
vergonzosos entonces a mí la policía no
me simpatiza mucho le si tengo un
problema no necesariamente los voy a
llamar a mí me han controlado dos veces
en toda tu vida solamente dos veces en
mi vida pero las dos veces fue porque
estaba con amigos afrodescendientes y
árabes
desde nivel de dos imágenes
tensión
explíquenme cuando salieron la última
vez que pasó y después que hicieron
bueno
juliette se dio cuenta que a menudo se
ponía el sufrimiento de los judíos y el
sufrimiento de los afrodescendientes
entonces decidió que sería bueno
trabajar con los dos sufrimos el
sufrimiento es el mismo no hay que
compararlos porque en los dos casos es
difícil para ambas partes nosotros
hablamos sobre los judíos por primera
vez en 3º de primaria bueno sobre el
conflicto de los judíos por primera vez
en 3º de primaria
la película la redada la había en cuarto
de primaria pero sobre la esclavitud y
todo eso solo hablamos en bachillerato
hay que relacionar eso con el hecho de
que se habla mucho sobre la shoah es
decir no estoy segura de que si mañana
se habla menos sobre la soja entonces se
hablará más entiendes no creo que eso
sea una equivalencia creo que uno puede
hablar mucho sobre la soja y hablar
mucho sobre lo que pasó en áfrica estoy
sobre la esclavitud y sobre el
colonialismo ves no se trata de una
balanza
dice
y sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
no
[Música]
y libera la palabra el primer año a mí
me dieron ganas de comprometerme y de
pensar sobre esos temas y de ir a hacer
un tour con ellos
[Música]
creo que ahora es nuestro turno con
jóvenes de asumir nuestras
responsabilidades y decir que nosotros
en realidad lo rechazamos es soportable
y también es nuestro turno es decir
miren si podemos vivir en el aire sería
un poco más ligero en nuestro país y los
portadores de la fraternidad se tomarán
la palabra que tomaran el control
retomar la dinámica y se dijeran es
nuestro turno
[Música]
después
entonces
francia somos nosotros gracias por
habernos dado la oportunidad de retomar
el hilo de la conversación gracias
pasa que esta emisión de reporteros el
documental de france 24 si le gustó el
reportaje puede verlo nuevamente a
través de nuestra página web france24
puntocom hace una próxima oportunidad
[Música]